I had a question about when you, you, some of the other programs on the rife machine and say,
for example, I was trying to find something for the plantar fish. I hiss on my foot and I really couldn't
find that in the programs, but I used one for tendonitis. And my question is, is if I only, I have the
tube, if the tube is the only, the Tesla tube is the only thing I have. Do I, do I play that right on the
foot, or if I was doing something for sinuses, would you place that closer to your sinuses or your
head area? Does the, the tube need to be closer to the area that you're trying to affect? Good question.
All right, I got to mute everybody and I'll answer that. So in when you're looking at other
programs on the rife to use, there's not a program for every single thing, right? So let's say I have
plantar fasciitis and it's like, oh, I can't find a plantar fasciitis program. But I found this tendonitis
program or I found this swelling program or I found this, this accelerated healing program.
Would that be a good one to use, first of all? The answer is, we don't know, just try it.
And I don't say that facetiously. I say that to help you understand frequencies.
Just because even if there was a program for plantar fasciitis, does not mean it's going to work for
everybody's plantar fasciitis because everybody's plantar fascia and healing the plantar fascia might
take a little bit different frequency. So you might have to try some different programs.
So always look for ones just like you did, Patty, that seemed to be similar in nature.
What am I go to in favorite ones is the accelerated healing program. It's in the normalizing
frequencies folder. So it's in the folder that says normalizing frequencies. And I think it's the
first or second, what it's called accelerated healing. That one is great for muscle aches and
pains and damage and torn ligaments and different things like that. And then the second part of the
question is, where do we place the bulb? It's always best to place the bulb as close to the area
that you're trying to treat. That's why it's like, okay, if I have prostate cancer, where should I
place the bulb? We'll put it next to you. Yeah, it'd be good to hug it right down by your prostate.
If I have breast cancer, should I put the bulb right over my breasts? Well, that would be best,
as long as it's not shining at your eyes and keeping you awake. So you have a balance there.
But then if I run into a program during the day for a specific body part, then yes, you're better off
having the bulb close to that body part. It's somebody's chatting me here. But it's you're
going to have better results the closer it is to that body part. Yeah, if I had plantar fasciitis
program and I was holding the bulb in my head, would I still have some benefit? Yes. But you're going to
have better benefit closer to the body part. Second part of that question that you didn't really ask was,
is the hammer tube the best bulb for everything? Well, the answer is the hammer tube has enough
output that you could run any of the programs except the math programs with the hammer tube and you'll
be just fine. However, if you're going to be concentrated on a specific thing, then there are some
other bulbs that can be beneficial and you can look on RIFE's website or you can contact us or ask
the question on Facebook, which would be a really good question for everybody to hear, is where would
you use different bulbs? And maybe I'll put together a little thing for you too. There's what's called
Zinger bulb, which is a real nice bulb for like a tissue massage and working muscles or working
to skin cancer or some tissue area would be really good for plantar fasciitis. There's a spiral bulb,
which I guess I would know where I'd recommend the spiral bulb for except for skating. And then there's
the double bubble bulb, which there's that can be beneficial for certain things too, but really the
hammer bulb and maybe the Zinger bulb would be two bulbs to have with the foot bath. Somebody
commented on your issue with plantar fasciitis that they bought a pair of VIO VIO-NUC sandals and shoes
and they made a world of difference. I would also comment that I started wearing flip flops last
summer, just some really nice Nike flip flops that seemed super comfortable. But I had up with
plantar fasciitis two and I had to go back to my Birkenstocks and it took about five, six weeks of
back onto a good pair of Birkenstocks to have finally my plantar fasciitis completely disappeared.
And I didn't even run any rife programs for it. I wear arch supports in my dress shoes at work.
I've worn them forever and then I wear Birkenstocks. Even in the winter I have these Birkenstock clogs
that I wear or I wear tennis shoes with a good arch, but I don't only use those if I'm going
bicycally to work it out or something like that.